we're here to present um the billion
request content recommendation system
challenge so uh my name is El langl
standing next to me are my colleague sin
T and AR desana and we work for the
company called chartbeat so chartbeat is
a company that provides analytic
solutions for media and uh H media and
publishing companies um we work with a
lot of Industry leaders including our
next door neighbor the New York Times um
earlier this year we acquired company
called tubular Labs tubular is a company
specializes in Social video intelligence
so chbe and Tu together we work with
companies in 80 countries six continents
and we track more than 790 billion page
views and 100 billion of minutes of
watch time each year and I've already
mentioned we've uh had our presence in
six continents so that means we're
working very hard to crack the
Antarctica market so if you have any
local connections there I don't know
like penguin daily please let us know
we're more than happy to talk to you
after the
presentation all right so we are here to
today to talk about recommendation
system um a lot of the you know like the
talks in the DS oriented conference
usually is about the
um uh the algorithm side of things so
today we're actually going to walk you
through a more you know like how do we
build a scalable recommendation system
from an engineering perspective we will
first introduce you with our unique uh
unique and interesting challenges that
we're facing for our recommendation
system that set us apart from more
traditional implementation of uh
recommendation system in e-commerce or
movie recommendation then we'll give you
a quick overview of how we generate uh
our recommendations a majority of the
presentation today will be actually
spent on uh kind of discussions around
architectural consideration caching
strategy how we use load testing to
evaluate
performance um okay so first thing
challenges we have identified four
challenges first one constantly I
constantly changing item space
um so uh our customers together
published more than 10,000 articles uh
on a very bus day in just one minute but
in the meantime 25% of them actually no
longer receive meaningful traffic just
after 1 hour of being published um that
means our system has to uh adapt to a
continuous uh stream of new articles and
expiration of old ones Second Challenge
diverse content Dynamics among sites and
articles what do I mean here so we have
you know time sensitive articles like
news coverage or disaster coverage we
also have Evergreen content that were
published a long long time ago but are
consistently generating traffic we have
also have old articles that published
long before and suddenly become relevant
or we call it resurrect so in terms of
sites we have sites wanted to promote
popular articles to attract you know
broad audience we also have sites that
want to promote Niche articles to keep
their loyal readers on the site so when
we build our system we have to consider
all those different perspectives into
our uh into our design third challenge
is about the speed and scale
requirements of our implementation so
our intended use cases of API is to be
implemented from the client side as
opposed to the server side so there are
multiple reasons for that for one some
of our customers insist on only
implementing R API on the client side um
and second the client implementation
actually allows us a lot more get into a
lot more visibility into who are viewing
and clicking to our recommendation third
um the uh client sign implementation
allow ows us to have a lot more control
over our own system right but it also
comes with significant infrastructure
undertaking we need to be able to scale
up to 1.3 billion page views a day and
we also need to generate recommendations
very fast because for one we don't want
to slow down the page that our customers
need to spend a lot of energy and effort
on
optimizing uh second 30% of reader
actually spend less than one second on
an article so we need a c readers
attention while they're still at it okay
last but not least sparse user item
interaction this is not a you know like
a an unfamiliar challenge that usually
faced with the CH uh recommendation
system but in our case it's kind of
extreme so we have 30% visitors actually
visit the site for the first time in the
last 30 days and a majority reader like
you and me we don't read a ton of
Articles every time we visit a site
right so we actually see 80% article
only has less than three page views a
day so for each of the challenges I have
outlined here our general approach for
each one of them for the first one um
sparse user item interaction we're going
to focus on popularity base and content
based recommendations at least for now
um for the constantly changing item
space um we are going to we have a crown
a batch a batch process a crown job that
runs every few hours to refresh our
candidates for the scale and speed
requir ments we adopted a webq worker
architecture and put a lot of thoughts
into our caching strategy last one the
dynamic contents among sites and
articles we allow users to customize
their recommendation using a variety of
API parameters now AR and Sinclair are
going to focus a lot more on the
architectural considerations and API
parameters um including why and how
those API parameters actually pose a
challenge to our caching strategy and
how do we solve that um but for now I'd
like to introduce you to or give you a
quick overview of how our
recommendations are get actually get
generated okay so as I mentioned we have
two ways of recommending articles first
one is popular popularity based second
content based right um but those are not
you know the not the fancy algorithms um
and in fact they're the most common ways
to gener recommending items um but we
have added our own flavor to them
so for top popularity based
recommendation we recommend top trending
articles but also incorporating reader
Behavior so if you're a reader reading
an article article on your mobile device
we actually are going to recommend you
top tring articles on mobile because
they might be different from training
articles on desktop we also consider
where you are um the region the readers
are from and how do how do the readers
get to the page whether through search
or social um we call it referr so on the
right hand side is a a quick example of
of our popularity based recommendation
um it's for the site called snopes.com
snopes.com is a fact checking site there
are a lot of interesting content on that
site so I highly recommend you to check
it out um so what what do we have here
we have something about NFL uh Arnold
schwas zegar um and uh the shooting in
main okay so for Content based
recommendations we are going to
recommend articles that are similar to
the one the reader is currently reading
we call it Target article um in the
meantime we also wanted to consider the
engagement matrics of those
recommendations so for example if an
article is very similar to the one that
the reader is currently reading but no
longer is generating you know meaningful
traffic we actually don't want it don't
want it to recommend it because it's no
longer relevant to our readers right um
so on the right is a example of the
content based recommendation um our
Target article is thus decorative spider
webbing POS a danger to Wildlife it's an
article on snoop.com um we uh choose
this metric called of weighted average
engage time we also had a Feer on the
publish date what we have here is
something about honeybees uh Turtle
octopus hybrid um carpet python baby PE
peacock and a person in be costume so
went quite good with you know generating
relevant contents to our um Target
article and um by the way the UI you're
seeing here like the bottom part is a
Chrome extension that we buil on top of
our API to allow um editorial teams to
quickly preview and curate the
recommendations okay so how does it
work this is a general diagram of our
architecture you'll see this diagram uh
repeated throughout the
pration um Sinclair and AR are going to
spend uh more time talking specific
component of the the diagram but for now
all you need to know is a majority of
the recommendation generation process
happens in the worker um so what I just
talked about is the popularity based
recommendation and we have three workers
to handle that device region and refer
each associate with the reader Behavior
Dimension um and the workflow is simple
we highly uh rely on our existing
real-time tracking system to recommend
top trending articles and as I mentioned
we also consider different reader
behavior dimmension um for Content based
recommendation we have a separate Pro a
separate con U independent of the worker
but still uh recommendations are
generated in the
worker so let's see how it works um
first uh let's start with the batch
process it's a crown that runs every few
hours to make sure that we refresh our
candidates um we get articles metadata
engagements we also and and then we um
generate embeddings um for each one of
those article and using sentence
Transformer um and we save all those
information in
Radice when it comes to uh actually
generating recommendation we actually
generate recommendation After we receive
the request so not before the request
but after um I think a lot of times the
traditional implementation of rexus is
actually having the recommendation
pregenerated in our case because we
generate after words we call it online
prediction so we use three types of uh B
uh features the first one is batch
feature that we generated in the crown
second one online feature we generate um
After we receive the request um usually
for newly published articles that we
haven't seen before and we need to
generate features for them on the spot
the last one is a realtime feature or
real time metric it tells us how many
people are reading this article right
now at this very moment okay how does
does it work so we have embeddings for
the candidate articles right and we have
embeddings for the Target article we can
easily calculate a similarity score um
but we don't end end here we also need
to consider the engagement metrics so we
take a balanced view of a similarity
score and engagement metrics and get the
top performing similar articles now the
user can choose to rank those articles
based on realtime metric based on how
many people are reading the articles um
at this very moment um and after you
know all this candidate retrieval
scoring and reranking we are finally
able to get a our final set of
recommendations and we save that in
reddis now you know have a great idea of
how the recommendations are generated AR
and Sinclair are going to spend a lot
more time on how we serve those those
recommendations to meet the requirements
and challenges I mentioned earlier
okay
thanks elain um hi everyone so before we
get into the architecture itself I
wanted to talk briefly about where the
request is coming from our customers
would be hitting the recommendations
engine from the front end of their
website this means that to ensure that
the readers of their websites have a
seamless experience we would need to
make sure that we return timely and
quality responses to the request
we should also be able to support a
large number of requests since the
client side implementation that Elaine
referred to before on our customers
website means that every new P page load
is essentially a new request so the 1.3
billion page views translate to 1.3
billion requests so um we previously
discussed the process for recommendation
generation let's now talk about uh how
we ensure quick responses from our
system
um let's look in a bit more at our webq
worker architecture when the request
first comes in it hits our server and we
ask a very important question that is
have you seen this request before in
this case let's assume that the answer
is no now based on the parameters that
were passed in the URL request we
publish a job to the rabbit Q we use
rabbit mq here for uh maintaining our
Rex Q here the job spec contains
parameters that the worker would need to
generate the uh
recommendations this includes the target
article we are generating for the
recommendations for the domain of the
customer uh as well as other optional
parameters like the desired freshness of
the recommendations and the number of
recommendations at the same time we also
need to make sure that we are uh
returning a response to our customers so
we make a call to a realtime tracking
the realtime tracking services to return
the top trending articles for that
particular host domain as placeholder
recommendations here the placeholder
recommendations or the trending articles
are not really fulfilling the request
parameters that were specified by the
customers but they're just something
that we return for the time being while
the actual requests are uh being
generated in the worker and stored in
the Cash
Store uh this means that the next time
we receive the same request we have the
recommendations actually satisfying the
request the reason why we do this is to
ensure that if our customer is using our
response to populate a certain section
on their website we always have
something to show
there in the meantime the worker uses
the job spec to generate the
recommendations according to the
parameters that we specify in the URL
params and again here when I say URL
parameters it means um the number of
recommendations the fresh value as well
as the article that we are generating
recommendations for all of these are
used by the
worker now that we have the
recommendations we also store them in
the redis store which Sinclair will be
talking about in uh much more detail
later on in the
presentation so now that we know that we
have seen this request before let's ask
this question again if we repeat the
same request what happens have we seen
this request before yes well then it's
pretty straightforward we immediately
check the reddish store and we find an
instant uh hit in our reddish store we
return the recommendations right away
giving an giving us an almost
instantaneous
response so in this way our complete
webq worker architecture helps us create
a product that can support a large
number of requests I will now pass on
the mic to Sinclair for a much deeper
dive into the working of our red
store
thank you very much
arer so here's this image again showing
our overall
architecture I'm going to focus on this
little bit down here uh Elaine made this
magnifying glass for me I think it's
pretty impressive uh so this is what
we're talking about should be clear uh
this is a really important part of our
system so as Acer just mentioned the
first time we see a request you go to
New York times.com you see a very
interesting article the first time you
go to that article first time anybody
goes to that article we're going to
generate recommendations in our workers
but all subsequent visits to that page
recommendations will be served from our
cach so this is our cach down here which
we call the Rex store so the vast
majority of requests are getting served
directly out of this cach so it's a very
important part of our system I wanted to
talk to you about it today because we
got this completely wrong the first time
we tried to build it uh I'm going to
tell you how we got it wrong and how we
fixed the
problem so so I'm going to start with a
high level overview of how this works
and it works very similarly to any cache
so over here you've got some computation
I've called it computation one and you
want to get the result for this
computation the first time you do this
you're not going to have anything in
your cache so you're going to have to do
this slow process to get the result for
that computation but once you do this
the first time you can save it back to
your cach and then when you go and ask
for the results of this computation
again you can just get it directly from
the cash cache much more quickly if you
have the second computation it's a
different computation you can't just use
that first result so you have to go
generate the result again save it back
to the cash and look it up again so this
is basics of caching maybe some of you
have seen this before maybe some of you
haven't I think there's a very
interesting issue here which I didn't
quite appreciate until I tried to start
building our recommendation store uh
which is that computation one and
computation two are different and you
need it some way of tracking how they're
different um and there's a question
almost of the identity of a computation
in your cache how do you match up you
know computation one to Result One and
computation two to result two I'm sorry
this presentation should have had a
seizure
warning
um so there's a very simple strategy
that is probably the one that most
people use which is just you consider
the inputs to your computation and if
all the inputs are the same then that is
the same
computation uh I don't know you can call
it the input identity
strategy um so this is what we did the
first time round uh and it led to
problems this is kind of more in detail
now the way that we implemented it we
used redis this has come up a couple
times in the in the slid so far but if
you're not familiar with redus it's a
very fast key value store it's in memory
and so we're saving all the
recommendations we generate into
redus
uh to pull something out of redus you
need a key and so for we're going to
adopt this input identity strategy to
generate our cache Keys how are we going
to do
that we're going to use all the inputs
to our recommendation generation to form
a
key and so here's an example of a key in
our system as we first designed it and
you can see it's very long and terribly
ugly and it's hard to read and it's
actually I've even cut it off because it
just goes on and on and on this is
terrible I mean it's just what is
that the reason it was so long is
because our endpoints take a lot of
parameters uh we wanted to support these
as features we wanted it to be a very
flexible API uh Russell's still figuring
out how people will use it frankly so
we've got lots of options um but because
there are so many parameters if we take
this input identity strategy to
identifying things in our cache uh we
have to factor in all these parameters
into our keys uh and this is just
outlining you know what all these
different things are so we've got the
domain we've got the path to the art
article and then a bunch of different
other parameters that do various other
things uh in our
API uh so not only are the keys very
long but because they're so long the
kind of key space is very large you know
each parameter produces like each
variation of one parameter produces a
different key so there are lots of
different keys and as a result we have
to be prepared to store things in redus
for all these different Keys uh and that
would require a lot of storage and this
is in memory so it's going to be very
expensive uh so this first draft of the
Rex store system had all these different
problems uh so we thought how do we do
better uh can we just strip parameters
out of the key can we use fewer
parameters and you might be thinking
okay that seems sensible but now you
have this problem right if you just take
off all the parameters at the end and
only consider the first
two don't you go back to this problem of
okay maybe we you know change something
way down here in the key this parameter
is now different but because that's no
longer in the key you can see the first
part of the key is the same so aren't we
going to end up maybe accidentally
confusing things that we stored in our
Rus data
store uh it turns out that this wasn't
that important um and we were able to
strip out the parameters at the end and
let me kind of just walk you through why
that was if you think about just taking
those first two parameters it's almost
conceptually as if you have this slot
that is reserved in our c
for a particular
article uh and so here is an example of
a New York Times article it maps to this
slot because it's got this key and when
we generate recommendations we cach them
in this slot and serve it for future
requests if we have a different article
it gets mapped to a different slot um
and we save recommendations there and
serve them for future requests the
interesting scenario is what if we have
a request for recommendations for this
same article but with a different
parameter uh one that is not included on
our key under this new system that will
map to the same slot and I sort of say
slot because this then gets overwritten
and we have this idea in our application
code of an unsatisfied hit so like this
key exists in reddis but what we store
there is not really what we want and so
we do this equality comparison on our
recommendations in application code to
see if this is really what we want if
it's not uh it gets
overwritten uh and something new is
slaved in that slot uh
and this works
because basically we realized that these
parameters are not going to change very
often on an article to article basis so
yes we're only including the article
domain and path in the key but that is
enough because most of the time these
parameters will be the same for every
single article if they vary they will
vary article to article but that's
already captured in our key so sometimes
we might overwrite things we had to
support that because that could happen
but it's unlikely to affect the
performance of our cach because it
happens so
rarely so this worked well for us it had
lots of benefits the keys are not so
terribly ugly we didn't have to store so
much stuff the performance of our cach
was still pretty good there were some
additional application code we had to
add and that increased the complexity of
it a little bit but we figured that was
a reasonable tradeoff uh to
make So speaking of performance I'm
going to hand it off to aery who will
tell you about how we evaluated the
performance of our system over
thank you Sinclair um now that we have
understood the working of our system in
general uh we want to be able to
evaluate the performance of the engine
as we have specified throughout this
presentation um scalability is of utmost
importance for our project we want to be
able to handle a l large number of
requests from our customers really fast
a typical load test for the
recommendations engine involves making
requests through a web service Tool uh
called Vegeta we make uh requests at a
steady rate while monitoring the
performance uh at the end of the test uh
Vegeta gives us the average response
latencies the status codes and the
success ratios of the test
requests so we have established um
throughout this presentation that there
are two important components through our
system namely the web Q worker
architecture which I covered before and
the caching which Sinclair just
discussed we want to be able to uh test
both aspects both of these aspects of
our system um so it is now helpful to
view a single test run or a single load
test uh in two distinct halves the first
half is when we are making the test
request for the first time now if you
recall from the architecture overview
earlier in the presentation we mentioned
that the first time we are making a
request the recommendation engine
Returns the trending articles and
submits the job for cashing the articles
that actually satisfy the request uh to
the
worker uh so during the load testing we
should be repeating the request to test
that the recommendation generation
process uh went through without a glitch
and uh then repeating the request to
verify that we are getting the cash uh
recommendation satisfying the request uh
This Way both halves of our system can
be evaluated
in so let's talk first about the rec
generation process um when we are making
the request for the first time we would
be testing the interaction between the
server q and the worker essentially
testing what happens when the answer to
the key question we mentioned before
have we seen this request before is
no uh it's a test of the capabilities of
our web Q worker
architecture so how do we know that the
reg generation process was successful
well there are quite a few metrics that
we could look at to evaluate this first
up we have the Q depth of the rabbit Q
we are using to for uh getting the
recommendation jobs uh the Q depth
indicates that at any point of time what
is the rate at which the jobs for
generating recommendations are being
published to the queue from the
server so here for instance to the right
we
have here for instance to the right we
have uh the chart from grafana that we
use to monitor uh the Q depth in general
we would want to make sure uh that the
QEP is not steadily increasing because
that would indicate that the worker is
stuck and the jobs are not being
completed um next up we have the Q
throughput that is essentially the rate
at which the worker is picking up jobs
from the queue this metric is indicative
of the health and efficiency of the
worker
so at the right uh we have uh the Q
through P note that we want the green
and yellow lines here in the graph to
always be approximately close to each
other for an efficient test run because
that would mean that the jobs are being
published to the Queue at approximately
the same rate at as the rate at which
they are being um picked up by the
worker from the
queue and finally we also need to make
sure that the first time that we are
making a request we are getting uh back
the trending articles so to monitor this
we could look at the status codes for uh
all of our requests and we want to see
200 response codes throughout our load
test of course to make sure that the uh
the system is working as
expected um so we can see that we use
metrics such as Q depth q throughput and
number of successful responses to make
sure that the recommendation generation
process went through without a hiccup
next up we want to see how our cach is
performing so coming to the second half
of the low test we want to monitor the
interaction between the server worker
and the redus host um we assume here
that each of the recommendation uh each
of the requests we made in the first
half of the load test should be in
cached in the Redd store by now so we
should be getting almost instantaneous
responses from our
engine um in the this half of the uh
Lotus we primarily look at metrics for
the Cash
Store so first up we look at the cash
hits um these are the number of um hits
we see when we are looking into the re
store for each
request um so we can see that uh here in
green we have the cash hits for uh the
second half of the test we would want to
see only cash hits because we should
have each uh request cached in the
store another thing we would want to
look for is Cash misses so this is a
number of times that we did not find
satisfying recommendations in the Cash
Store this is highlighted here in yellow
and during the first half of the test
ideally we would only see cash misses
and the second half we should be seeing
none uh none of the cash
misses and finally uh we also want to
keep track of the number of successful
job completions in the worker which
means means that each job for each
request was successfully finished and
cash in the r store um this graph here
shows us the number of completions over
a given time period uh this should
increase throughout uh the test and uh
cut off somewhere as we start the second
half of the test uh so cash hits cash
misses uh and successful completions can
all be leveraged to determine the cash
performance now that we know the metrics
uh let's look the look at the
performance of our system so we started
off this section by saying that we
wanted to see if we could serve really
fast responses and handle a large number
of requests from our customers so let's
first talk about our ability to handle a
large number of requests with caching uh
in this graph here on the left uh we see
how our Q throughput was before we
implemented caching uh we can see that
before there was a huge disparity
between the rate at which we were
publishing the jobs to the queue versus
the rate at which they were being uh
picked up by the worker this changed
after we implemented the caching and we
can see on the right that the worker is
very efficiently able to keep up with
the queue
here and finally let's see uh at our
oops sorry uh let's see uh how fast we
return responses so here we have a
comparison between the Veta output we
had from one of our older test runs
versus the latest one after implementing
the webq architecture so uh we see here
uh that our uh request latencies have
significantly improved in particular we
can see uh the average latency before
was around 2 seconds which we have since
brought down just to a few milliseconds
you may also notice that the max latency
for the request before was around 27
seconds
which has been uh brought down to 1
second the reason why it was so high
before was because we were generating
recommendations in our server and
sometimes uh we would get hung up on a
single request leading to a much higher
backlog weight time uh we have since cut
it down because we moved the
recommendation generation process to the
worker so again this is a testament to
the changes we have made to incorporate
the web Q worker architecture and the
caching in our recommendations engine
I'll now pass on the mic to Sinclair to
make a few closing
remarks thank you
arti um okay so why do you care about
this system that we
built uh I think I'm gonna come back to
that slide but basically this
architecture worked well for us so I
don't know if any of you in the future
may build recommendation systems um but
this is something that we thought worked
well we started out with a system uh
that was not very well architected and
as a result we had a very poor mean
Laten for our requests and as AR just
showed you we were able to get that down
by almost two orders of magnitude I
think the huge win here was just moving
a lot of the heavy data science
recommendation work uh into these
workers and then being able to serve the
vast majority of the requests from the
cach that worked really well as an
overall approach but as you've also
heard there were also some subtleties we
had to consider along the way as we uh
built that it worked really well for us
we had all of these challenges to deal
with um I think the biggest ones were
probably that we have this long tale of
articles that we still want to generate
recommendations for even though they get
very few uh page views uh and then we
also had to generate the requests uh
very quickly and serve them at a a very
large
scale um I think maybe another takeaway
from this is uh although of course uh
data science was an important part of it
it kind of like is this little part here
and the rest of it was you know
infrastructure and Engineering so if you
want to build a recommendation system at
scale uh these engineering problems are
going to be a big part of it in addition
to the the data science the data science
ended up being relatively
straightforward for us elen is our ml
engineer on the team it's possible she's
just really good at her job and it just
never came
up but I think there are some inherently
uh hard engineering problems to solve
building a system uh at this
scale thank you very much and